oui madame perez oui une seconde je je
m'occupe de ma cliente et après je
reviens vers vous non il y aura pas toi
on aura tout le temps de parler ma mère
a tout à leur banc nantais 6 oui non
rester là reste à après je revienne
d'accord excusez-moi isabelle maalox et
espagnols qu'est-ce que sont bavards mon
dieu ne m'en parlez pas j'avais une
voisine qui étaient espagnols et les
kebabs ce moment elle était bas
excusez moi allez si ali rial et je vous
écoute isabelle été bavard banger et est
bardée faisait que parler
comment s'appelait déjà ça suffise du
tour en onze espagnol il est souvent
loupé sa chaise à mariette hangar c'est
en tout cas vous avez l'air de péter le
feu en pleine forme a ri si vous arrivez
je reviens de passer une semaine de
vacances à vierzon angers ah oui quand
même
je suis allé avec nouvelles frontières
après il faut ni voyage là bas
maintenant dire au départ handball et
aux baléares et comme on était passé
nombreuses dans maya vieira va faire
recours que me vole ab oui on n'a pas de
piller les ailes on est allé sur c'est
sûr c'était bien bien sont aussi calme
deux hommes c'est reposant c'était pour
ça mon dieu que c'est calme le troisième
jour je dis à ma copine quel jour on est
maudit mercredi encore motta temps
compte double à vierzon oui c'est cette
manière qu'ils ont organisé le
couvre-feu de 18h oui il avait pris de
l'avancé sur le prix mais pas en bien
confiné depuis toujours
[Rires]
voté par contre le real et sont bien rob
est ce que vous avez à crever vous êtes
cernés comme un chanteur
on ne parlait pas c'est mon mari et sa
libido ne s'est pas vrai ça commence le
soir à table
il me regarde droit dans les cinq ils
m'offrent des fleurs là je me dis toi
des bornes pour écarter les jambes parce
que vous n'avez pas de base mais moi mon
dieu je suis bête jamais vous aimez plus
apte et excusez moi j'aime rire oui ça
tombait bien à la grosse rigolade c'est
parfait les vus j'ai re décorer le
magasin j'ai pas hésité sur la lumière
et eau vous êtes fatigués fatigue monde
parlait par richard csu non c'est vrai
que c'est toujours pareil oui mais mais
justement quand même y était je fais
coin bigard vous parler de mon mari et
on parlait du vase mon mari les lie ils
commandent ces milliards de droits
d'années s'est noyé et là il me malaxe
la poitrine il est là oui je fais venir
je vais venir
oui monsieur frédéric je vais venir une
soleil la plage et maquillage après oui
voilà mais dites-moi quand même il vous
oblige pas attendez on est catholique on
n'est pas obligé d'être pratiquante
[Rires]
or là il concluant poussa un cri
horrible on dirait une grosse vache
éventrée qui se vide c'est terrible ça
doit réveiller les enfants ne criait
comme ça non non attendez je suis
prévoyez un telle histoire de fleurs je
le remets 1/2 temesta d'allada net et
vous au moins vous savez ah oui c'est
vrai depuis qu elle est divorcée oui
sexuellement je suis bien tranquille on
est en jachère
oh oui et ça fait un moment que
j'attends ce [ __ ] de tracteurs de
marque et vierzon menait au chant et sa
série quéré non mais il faut patienter
mais attention moi comme je dis toujours
les hommes il faut se méfier les hommes
vous savez c'est la pochette surprise
quand j'ai dit où sont les hommes c'est
comme la neige on sait jamais combien
voire de centimètres ni combien de temps
va tenir huit mois je suis étonné nous
sommes vendredi d'habitude tous les
vendredis françois se fait coiffer un
côté de moi je ne la vois pas mais je
voulais pas dit norma burkinabé viendra
pas toucher les sommes non je n'aime pas
elle avait un empêchement rapport elle
est morte et bêta mieux face être malade
ça casse le moral de tout le monde
d'après moi c'est le coeur qui a dû
lâcher
mais c'est vrai que vous avez fait
médecine mais oui six ans et oui six
fois la première année ça fait des bases
solides
oui j'ai appris que la tête et ça me
sert bien à mon travail ici que vous
côté me changer de dois me fait un
taille crayon de la série d'attaqués
lancées voilà je vous fais moi niang a
fait basculer surtout fatma la suite
déjà je vais je merde avait les bigoudis
soutient ne pas refiler la mère de
rihanna fait bosse pas grave la suite la
suivre ça c'est à vous de parler là non
amoureux
je suis pas payé puisque j'ai dit mon
texte je parlais je me suis dit on va
m'aider mais non non non non non non non
non le texte ça fait notable par contre
si on me donnait la réplique que je
redémarre au bien de tous je connais par
coeur je vous ai pas dit oui justement
je n'ai pas dit que j'étais à vierzon
oui on n'est pas là le beau tout bas ça
fout des cons des concertos la de
l'accord allaient que j'interviens 11
un soir on dire audio à l'office du
tourisme pascal l'office du tourisme à
bien y aurait pas quelque chose à faire
au sens bien quand on dit si y'a
spectacle réglé 2 dans la télévision
vous savez les deux prises et à la mnef
cavaliers du fury c'est ça on y allait
m'ont dit que c'était bien mais que
c'était bien mais c'était bien le grand
était bon le petit est convaincant s'il
vous plaît alors à dd non à les prénoms
en france on a des nouvelles non c'est
vrai les bourses perdaient
puis tout à l'heure ça va pas changer
non non non rien et puis c'est un gros
ben bella keystone la terre ah oui je
pense qu'ils vont pas la laisser comme
ça oui non me dire ou es ce koh lanta
raoui jeudi à millau dans l'aveyron du
tsl alors affiché le monde jusqu'aux
élus commencent à tourner pour alain
millot reconnais pas si j'ai la gr b à b
tient en train de s'affronter en offrir
une à oui c'est vrai alors pour gagner
du temps je suis passé à des rafles aura
un bien est fondée comme positionne
mannix est très bien interflora céline
on ne la voyait tous les vendredis
c'était une amie il faut mettre le
paquet oui a fait céder 300 euros la
gerbe quand même je la connaissais pas
tant que ça il ya des bouquets de jaspe
n 1 100 euros qui sonne très bien sait
très bien que j'espère plus amer et
aveugle aurait rien bu tollé que je
serai s'appuiera le satyre pierre papin
ses voûtes et y aller toute façon ce
terme vous plaisantez ou quoi les venues
au miel non finement raisonner à les
trois hommes ou côté y aller vous non
chaque boucle allez c'est fini il y
avait quoi dans les petits filets au
nouveau c'est fini le travail voilà ta
gueule évidemment pas les
en écho le journal je reprochais reto
n'est ce pas sa pareille abattent année
il fallait voir d'où je suis parti je ne
me fera jamais cheval de course et je
paie that évidemment aller on dit ah ah
mercredi comme tous les mercredis
justement je vous demandais france
oui est-ce que mercredi prochain je ne
pourrais pas plutôt venir vendredi alors
exceptionnel parce que c'est vous c'est
la tempe vendredi ciel alors je viendrai
mercredi comme d'habitude et met
d'accord
[Applaudissements]